cuál es la diferencia entre un cristal
de carbono diamante
y un trozo de carbón amorfo
ya sabe usted
bueno la diferencia realmente son 12
millones de euros que es lo que costó la
pero efectivamente como han dicho por
ahí la diferencia está en el orden esa
es la mente la diferencia que existe los
cristales son la materia ordenada como
por ejemplo esos esos coches en ese
apartamiento o como por ejemplo estas
salas la butaca de esta sala están
perfectamente ordenadas periódicamente
ni a la distancia
idéntica unas de otras las filas una
distancia unas de otras es una orden
regular periódico simétrico esa es la
característica fundamental de los
cristales frente a los vidrios y los
amorfos en los cuales las moléculas las
macromoléculas los átomos están
completamente de ordenación de acuerdo
ese orden interno es absolutamente
fundamental eso es lo que caracteriza a
los cristales a la materia cristalina
sea cual sea
ya sean átomos y asia moléculas ya sean
macromoléculas lo importante lo
interesante lo que realmente caracteriza
al cristal es ese orden interno que es
el que le da las propiedades fantásticas
y tiene entre ellas por ejemplo la
morfología la morfología la forma de los
cristales que nos han fascinado desde
hace miles de años y que son unas formas
simétricas y unas formas planas unas
formas línea recta este edificio por
ejemplo cuando he salido al patio es un
edificio de arquitectura cristalina y
después lo pueden comprobar ustedes es a
esa morfología por ejemplo en el caso
del crudo de sódico el cloruro sódico la
estructura interna es un orden
repetitivo de cloro sodio cloro sobre
una estructura cúbica por lo tanto la
morfología del cristal la forma del
cristal de cloruro sódico de sal son
cubos el agua el agua cristaliza en el
sistema diagonal es decir las moléculas
de h2o son unas moléculas que se colocan
en un sistema según algunas columnas que
según algo y por tanto la simetría de
los cristales de agua de la seguridad de
los copos de hielo son esos bellísimos
copos de simetría hexagonal esto es algo
que no saben alguno
los diseñadores de las grandes
superficies que cada navidad se empeñan
en convencernos de que hay copos
octogonales no puede ser no puede ser
porque porque lo que manda la estructura
interna de estructura interna es
hexagonal los copos tienen que ser
hexagonales pero además de esas
propiedades morfológicas de la forma de
los cristales la estructura interna en
la que es las responsables de las
fantásticas propiedades que tiene los
cristales que usamos todos los días por
ejemplo hay una propiedad se llama
piezoelectricidad eso si usted coge un
cristal de cuarzo y le dan un golpe
genera una pequeña corriente eléctrica y
al revés si le hace pasar una corriente
eléctrica en el cristal el cristal vibra
como si fuera un diapasón eso lo
utilizamos todos los días por ejemplo
los relojes de cuarzo la precisión de
los relojes de cuarzo viene porque tiene
un cristal que es eléctrico en su
interior los mecheros cuando te vas al
machito eso es un cristal viso eléctrico
las ecografías todas las ecografías es
un peine de cristales piezoeléctricos el
sónar que llevamos utilizando desde hace
desde la segunda guerra mundial eso es
un cristales piezoeléctricos y por
supuesto todos los sensores de presión
en sus móviles todos esos son cristales
pisos vertidos
tienen otras propiedades fantásticas los
cristales de silicio que son los que
utilizamos para recoger la energía
fotovoltaica o los láser son también
cristales lo que hay detrás de ellos y
por supuesto todo lo que es la
microelectrónica todo el desarrollo de
la microelectrónica en los últimos 50
años está debido a los cristales de
sepyc semiconductores últimamente
también superconductores las pantallas
de cristal líquido son esos
lewis crystal display pantallas de
cristal líquido y porque si no el nombre
del silicon valley no es el valle de
california en que se desarrolló toda la
microelectrónica es por eso porque se
utilizaban los cristales de silicio son
la base de todo ese entonces realmente
los cristales tiene una propiedad
fantástica que podrían llevar todo el
día hablando de derecho no pero fijaros
que hay gente que además piensa no se
receptan contenta con esto sino que
además los cristales tienen propiedades
mágicas los padres tienen comunican una
cierta energía e incluso son capaces de
curar cuando yo doy esta una charla de
este tipo de sobre divulgación de los
cristales el mundo de los cristales
siempre al final de la charla vial
usted como experto que piensa en la
propiedad de magia de los cristales y
claro este poner un compromiso de objeto
es igual ahora que entonces yo decidí a
mí no me gusta llevar apuntar ya
entonces o sí sí decidir si los
cristales tiene unas propiedades mágicas
fantástico porque si usted por ejemplo
le regala a su mujer oa su marido oa su
hijo a su hija a su tío a su tía sube a
su amante le regala un diamante le entra
una cosa
se viene arriba arriba y sobre todo lo
que ocurre es que crea un cariño hacia
usted
absolutamente me gusta y eso a ver eso
lo estamos estudiando y hay una ley que
se llama la ley del cariño inducida
en el que tenemos aquí el cariño
inducido de saber cómo se mide frente al
número de quilates entonces es una ley
de tipo s es una ley de la ciencia en
muchos casos no entonces bueno el
diamante es de 234 quilates la región de
enamoramiento sabe no se enamora de
usted
fantástico bien pero cuando a 4 y es la
región de enloquecimiento la persona es
completamente loca es capaz de hacer lo
que sea y todas estas leyes de tipo s
tiene un punto de saturación que ya por
más que le regale más grande sea
diamante ya no es más incluso yo le
llamo a este punto de elizabeth taylor
en este caso porque se divorcian a ti
incluso si se hace está cansada de tanta
joya tanto de las y ya cuando los
diamantes son muy grandote pues tenemos
entonces lo que es negación de capital
que para lo que sirven
además
esta es como muchas leyes es reversible
es decir que si usted le quita diamante
no solamente te deja de querer sino que
se va te odia se va a la parte negativa
del eje bueno esto simplemente es una
broma
bueno para que me atiendan ahora porque
realmente ahora es lo que interesa
explicarle el verdadero poder de los
cristales y es que necesito hacer un
experimento tiene un elemento muy simple
estos son dos imágenes de microscopio
metroscopia un muy normalito esto es un
pañuelo de seda es un pañuelo cristalino
como veis porque están las fibras de
seda perfectamente ordenadas y esto es
un pañuelo de celulosa un kleenex en el
que las fibra de celulosa están
completamente desordenado de acuerdo
entonces la pregunta es si no tuviéramos
un microscopio como podríamos tener
conocer una imagen tener una imagen como
esa que tenemos ahí entonces hay una
forma de hacerlo que se llama difracción
se llama difracción y es vamos a hacer
el experimento yo creo que esto va a
valer así está voy a utilizar
se trata simplemente de lo siguiente es
utilizar un as del humor cromática como
este un láser que tiene una longitud de
onda similar a la distancia entre las
fibras que hay allí entonces cuando yo
le doy lo que iluminó este pañuelo
celulosa lo que tengo es un puntito de
la del láser y al traidor toda una serie
de puntos completamente desordenado
lovaisa y no y ahora vamos a hacer el
pañuelo
esto no es magia pero casa
y entonces hacer la misma de mi vida
veis
pues los criptógrafos hemos desarrollado
en los últimos años una teoría para que
sabiendo
dónde están esos puntos qué puntos son
los que hay que esos puntos son los que
falta la distancia entre los puntos la
intensidad de sus puntos el algo que hay
alrededor de cada uno de esos puntos
estudiando todo eso somos capaces de
crear esa imagen
y por eso la cristalografía es la
disciplina que más premio nobel ha
recibido en la historia más que
cualquier otra disciplina científica
seguro que ustedes están pensando y si
tenemos un microscopio para que tanto
rollo con esto bueno pues en cierta
medida llegó en razón lo que pasa es que
si lo que tú quieres conocer la
estructura de la textura de jade ese
pañuelo o quieres conocerla las alas de
una mariposa o quieres conocer cómo
están los cristalitos nano cristalitos
en tus huesos todo eso tenemos
microscopios pero si realmente lo que tú
quieres saber es cómo están los átomos
de una molécula por ejemplo de
paracetamol o de vitamina c o de la
insulina o del adn como están los átomos
colocados de tal forma que puedas
conocer exactamente el carnet de
identidad de esa molécula eso no evitó
el propio que pueda ser la única forma
de hacerlo es distracción de rayos y la
única forma por ejemplo es lo que tienes
que hacer bueno pues quieres conocer la
estructura de una proteína como por
ejemplo está protegido de la de la
lisozima de la insulina pues lo que
tienes que hacer es disolver la incluida
en un solvente hacer que cristalice y
eso sube
habitualmente no es fácil pero una vez
que está cristalizada decir todas
están colocadas de insulina una latita
de otras formando lo que hace es incidir
sobre ella unas en este caso tiene que
ser de una distancia en la longitud de
onda de una distancia similar a la de la
distancia entre los átomos de utilizar
un láser como éste lo que utilizamos son
rayos equis entonces aquí por ejemplo mi
colega nuestro laboratorio está tomando
un cristal que no lo vais a ver pero es
un cristal muy chiquitito son del orden
de 200 300 400 micras suficiente para
colocarlo delante de un haz de rayos x
y lo que vais a ver ahí es lo mismo que
es proyectado con el láser y el pañuelo
lo que tenemos es una serie de puntos y
con esa serie de puntos somos capaces de
resolver de conocer la estructura íntima
de la materia
esa es la razón por la cual la
cristología es importante y esa es la
razón por la cual nos pagan los
gobiernos nos deben de pagar más debe
más inversión en ciencia aprovechamos
para hacer más inversiones de ciencia
esto por ejemplo es un caso de mi
laboratorio hay muchos otros casos en el
mundo presente mil laboratorios hay una
empresa farmacéutica una empresa
farmacéutica que viene con una sustancia
que yo llamaba ete 743 que nueva
sustancia que ya habían comprobado todos
los análisis clínicos todos los estudios
de que era un anticancerígeno poderoso
el problema es que no la voy han podido
cristalizar y por lo tanto no podían
tener una estructura fundamentales y no
tenían el carné de identidad para
patentar ese fármaco y para producirlo y
está absolutamente seguro de que está
produciendo lo que tú realmente estás
diciendo que estás que está abusando no
entonces en nuestra bator yo lo
cristalizamos que no es un saludo que
sea fácil y una vez que tiene
proyectiles en la estructura de ese paco
y una vez que tiene estructura de forma
que la compañía entonces puede
perfectamente ir hacia adelante y seguir
pues lo que
43 hoy en día es en las farmacias del
yondelis que es el anticancerígeno más
poderoso para tejidos blandos
eso lo hace la cristalografía en más
ahora hemos está haciendo lo que se
llama diseño racional de fármacos por
ejemplo en el caso del sida ha sido
absolutamente fundamental para que la
gente no se muera necesita porque porque
esta es una enfermedad que no estaba
nueva que se utiliza ninguna vista para
nada entonces lo que lo que se hace es
lo que se llama como os digo diseño
racional de fármacos lo que hacemos es
que sabemos que todas las enfermedades
están ligadas al mal funcionamiento de
una proteína tienes que identificar esa
proteína se identifican las distintas
proteínas que estaban relacionadas con
el sida y entonces esas proteínas había
que sean proteínas dianas
tú lo que tienes que hacer es
cristalizar las y una vez que la
cristaliza las proteínas es una maraña
de átomos es una cosa absolutamente
inmensa pero tienen todas ellas tienen
cada una y es lo que le hace específico
tiene un acento activo que se llama que
es por donde se comunica con el mundo de
la proteína
ese es el dow activo es una caverna una
caverna que está rodeado de una serie de
átomos una serie de formas ahí entonces
una vez que tú has identificado eso lo
que tienes que conseguir es un fármaco
es decir una molécula vas diseñando a
moléculas que se vaya ajustando hasta
que se ajusta perfectamente como una
ayuda
una cerradura bloqueas dentro activos
eso es lo que se ha hecho conocida y eso
es la razón por la cual en unos poquitos
años fuimos capaces de crear una serie
de actividades que son los que hoy en
día hacen que la gente no se muera a
necesitar y eso es básicamente una
función gracias a la cristalización esa
es la razón por la cual la criptografía
tiene ese poder curativo que ayuda a
curar porque es la base de todo lo que
es la investigación en biomedicina
simbología estructural vosotros
recordáis en los años 1953 cuando lo
descubrieron el primero 1900 1960
watson y hay clic y podéis la estructura
de doble hélice del adn que también
participó el rosal inflan y aunque no le
dieron el premio nobel
es la estructura del adn se consiguió
gracias a la difracción de rayos x es
explicado seguimos estudiando
continuamente
el último premio nobel sobre de
cristalografía estructural es por la
estructura esta de aquí del ribosoma
esto es una fábrica de proteína una
fábrica fascinante de proteína además es
la diana de muchísimos antibióticos hoy
en día pero sobre todo es la fábrica de
proteínas que nos ayuda a entender la
vida la biología cristalografía no
solamente es una herramienta fantástica
para la biomedicina sino que además es
la herramienta que nos ayuda a entender
la vida a nivel molecular es decir
entender la vida yo siempre llevo
conmigo un cristal
yo os recomiendo que lleven energía no
sé yo si le vas a comunicar pero le va a
ayudar a no olvidarse del hotel de los
cristales son fundamentales para está
bien muchas gracias